hi I'm Erik Bosse and with the vendors
in-game behind us in looking ahead past
spider-man far from home Marvel fans
have now found ourselves in an
unfamiliar sensation uncertainty what
comes next in the MCU is still very much
a mystery and not a fun mystery like
squirrel search or Spidey duck hunt I
just feel so helpless Marvel Studios has
announced it will be returning to Hall H
at Comic Con this month during which
Kevin Feige will presumably make a
little cameo to announce the Marvel
phase 4 lineup in schedule just like you
did in October 2014 back when we all
still believed Feige about that Inhumans
movie that never happened oh well oops
there I'm gonna break down what that
lineup revealed at Comic Con might be
and everything we know at this point
about the future of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe ok the most immediate release
that we're waiting for information about
is Disney's upcoming streaming service
Disney Plus which will launch on
November 12 2019
there are currently 5 Marvel related
series that will stream on Disney Plus
Falcon and Winter Soldier will begin
production in October 2019 and is set to
premiere on the service in August of
2020
it'll star Anthony Mackie and Sebastian
Stan and could for all we know feature
old man cap or younger alternate reality
caps there will also be Marvel what if
an anthology series based on the
hypothetical premise spin-off comics
that will also come out within the first
year of the service with a pilot episode
focusing on what if Peggy Carter
received the Super Soldier Serum there's
also one division a series with Scarlet
Witch envision that will begin
production in fall 2019 as well and the
Loki series was announced with Rick and
Morty writer Mike Waldron to produce
with the premise being Loki affecting
events throughout human history and this
will come out in the second year of the
service probably sometime in 2021
meanwhile we are still waiting on
details for an untitled Hawkeye series
that sounds like it'll feature Clint
Barton
mentoring Kate Bishop but when it comes
to major theatrical releases the only
movie Marvel has in production from what
we know is Black Widow Scarlett
Johansson will star as Natasha Romanov
and what will likely be a 2006 prequel
in Budapest co-star in Florence pew
probably as rival spy Elena Bulova as
well as Rachel Weisz David Harbor Oh
teeth had been laying characters like
Hawkeye and Nick Fury could also make
cameos Kate Shortland is directing and
could be the movie that Marvel planned
for its mystery May 20 2014 3 but the
James Gunn drama delayed that release so
a more likely release date for Black
Widow would probably be November 2020
the next movie in the Marvel pipeline is
the Eternals in the Marvel Comics the
Eternals were an offshoot of the process
that created sentient life on earth the
Celestials created the Eternals
initially to defend earth and it led to
a war between the Eternals and the
deviants Angelina Jolie will star as
Cersei in a plot that has been described
as a love story with the character
Icarus who's gonna be played by Richard
Madden aka Robb Stark on Game of Thrones
also joining the cast will be Kumail
Nanjiani ma dongseok and Salma Hayek
Khloe Chou is directing and it's
speculated that this could release
sometime in summer 2021 moving on the
next movie that we know about is the
second Black Panther film director Ryan
Coogler is returning and the plan is to
start production in late 2019 or early
2020 which could mean a February 2021
release remember in Avengers endgame the
first characters to portal into that
final battle or who to Tallis Shuri in
Ocoee so that could be a sign for these
characters be the priorities for
Marvel's future next we also know that a
second Doctor Strange film is in the
works
scott derrickson will direct once again
and see Robert Cargill is coming back to
work on this script production is set to
begin in 2020 and this could be another
summer 2021 release or perhaps a
November 2021 release after the first
Doctor Strange came out in 2016
derrickson said that he was interested
in Nightmare as a future villain and if
he followed Erickson on Twitter which I
highly suggested he's a fascinating
follow he tends to post some cryptic
horror influences of his and images from
the Doctor Strange comics that could
indicate some kind of cosmic horror for
the sorcerer supreme
perhaps a journey into Hell itself
another Marvel film in the pipeline is
shang-chi with destined Daniel cretton
directing and David Callahan writing the
script that the goal is to avoid Asian
stereotypes that a direct adaptation the
comics might run into Ruby Lin and Ross
Butler are speculated to be considered
for the lead role and production will
begin after production for the Eternals
wraps so we might be seeing a shang-chi
movie dropping sometime early 2020 - and
that brings us to guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 now James Gunn has been
rehired to direct but thanks to all
that's due
but drama last summer production was
delayed to give James gun time to direct
Suicide Squad to for DC and time for the
rest of the cast schedules to line up
since this is very much an ensemble
movie and everyone needs to have time to
work together I'm thinking we might be
looking at a summer 2022 release for
this one now coming out of endgame who
suggested that it could be a possible as
guardians of the galaxy team up with the
work but James Gunn tweeted to stop
calling it as guardians of the galaxy
which might mean Thor won't be in this
movie or gun just doesn't like puns in
the title Gunn has said that he wants
the third movie to focus on the mystery
of Rockets origin perhaps related to the
character the High Evolutionary and of
course after that post-credits scene
from volume 2 Adam warlock will almost
certainly factor into the story and of
course we know at some point there will
be a third Tom Hollands spider-man film
probably with some home-related title
like you know can't go home again who
knows we could see that as early as
summer 2021 with another two year gap
considering far from home came out two
years after homecoming now the
post-credits scene for far from home
indicates a possible direction the third
movie could go go check out my breakdown
of the post-credits scenes for details
on that and similarly we'll probably get
a second Captain Marvel film which the
far from home post credits scenes also
might have shed some light on again
check out that breakdown but I'm
guessing the second film will introduce
the adult Monica Rambeau
aka spectrum who is established as a
child in the first one all of this said
Kevin Feige would be nuts if you didn't
plan on some major tentpole crossover
film considering phase 3 included Civil
War infinity war and endgame my bet is
that we will be seen an Avengers secret
invasion announcement
maybe Secret Wars and/or an introduction
of the Fantastic Four and along with
these other titles I've mentioned there
are several Marvel characters that Kevin
Feige has brought up as possible future
films this includes Nova whom Feige has
named and director Adam McKay mentioned
as they film being developed by Kia is
also mentioned kana Lacan who be the
future first Muslim American superhero
in the MCU Legion showrunner Noah Hawley
has said that he's written a Doctor Doom
script that Marvel Studios is still in
discussions with him about and according
to reports some character in this new
Marvel phase 4 will probably be played
by Keanu Reeves but who think we should
launch a new investigation series kion
who you don't love the title don't
bother saying so in the comments because
this is already a thing folks so what do
you think the mystery
May 20 21 major Avengers tentpole event
do you want to happen in phase 4 comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at EA boss and
subscribe to the rock stars for
breakdowns and theories about everything
Marvel related thank you for joining me
and I say about making fun of me maybe
not again
[Music]